um
so I want to say this probably starts
somewhere around
uh like around 2006.
I was living in New York City
where I was born and raised
and I was in a relationship
I was in a very long-term relationship
we were together his name was Michael
and he and I were together for
16 or 17 years something like that
and our relationship ended and it ended
uh amicably but it ended
um
and it was uh it was a very weird
experience having that relationship end
because we were together for so long and
he knew my family and I knew his
families and he was my family and so the
idea was the Assumption was that we were
going to be together forever that that
was just going to be it right uh but it
wasn't we just sort of grew apart and at
one point we sort of realized that we
were better
friends than we were
lovers
um
so that relationship ended and I had so
I mean my whole life was just in in
upheaval and had to figure out where to
live and all that stuff now you know how
when you are in
when you when you're in a relationship
that ends uh I I do this at least and
I'm sure a lot of people do this as well
um you you kind of get off on being
morose a little bit like I kind of
really got into the wallowing of it like
that you know the feeling the grief and
the
um and and the sadness of
of this the ending of this relationship
this whole new experience
um and you know how some people
um you know you sit there at night uh
with your headphones on and listen to
sad music or stuff like that you know
you really get into The Melancholy of it
so that's what I was doing
for sure I was absolutely wallowing in
it and I remember and there was one day
where I was on my computer
um
and I just kind of wanted to like find
sad poems I mean that's that's where my
headspace was I just needed I wanted to
find sad poems I wanted to be sad I
wanted to find poems specifically about
breaking up right
so so I go scouring through the internet
I you know looking for sad poems breakup
poems
and I found a lot of stuff of course
um but there was one poem in particular
that uh I found and it was that in fact
not sad at all
it was very um
it was very life affirming
it was very uplifting it was about
um
finding
that person the poem was in fact called
wait for him and that's the idea of the
poem like waiting for that person that
person is going to show up and and I
really loved it but it was on a weird uh
it was on a weird website it was on
somebody had just like put some put a
bunch of poems that they liked up on to
some site uh and the um and the poems
like didn't have the the person who did
this didn't have uh the um the author's
name on the poems or uh in fact
I think most of them didn't even have
like the titles of the poem it was it
was a weird little site I don't know how
I found it it was very random but anyway
but I loved this particular poem so much
um that I printed it out I didn't want
to lose it I printed it out
um actually on a very little piece of
paper and I folded it up and I put it in
my wallet I just thought I don't know
why I did that
um and I kept it in my wallet and it sat
in my wallet for years for many years
and every so often like maybe once a
year or maybe twice a year every six
months something like that I remember I
would remember that it was there and I
would take it out and I would read it
and I go oh my gosh yeah I love this
poem that's right I forgot blah blah
blah
so now cut to many years later I have
moved from New York City to Los Angeles
California
and I uh somebody sent me a friend
request on Facebook
um and uh
because I particularly hate Facebook
um I I would generally not accept a
friend request from a stranger
I I was really clear about you know only
accepting friend requests from actual
people like actual human beings that
I've met in real life
um however this guy who sent me this
friend request was really hot like
really super gorgeous and so I said oh
yeah oh yeah sure I'll be your friend so
I accepted his friend request and he
immediately wrote me uh wrote me on
Facebook and asked me out on a date
and of course I said yes
uh so we met and we were having dinner
again gorgeous in person which was
fantastic
uh his name was Antonio and we were
having dinner and you know as you do on
a date you start talking about uh you
know you just talk about yourself you
audition
um you do an interview and so we were
doing that and at one point it uh it
came up he said he really liked poetry
so I said and it was like oh do you wait
a minute hold on a second I have this
poem in my wallet it's my favorite poem
so I take it out of my wallet and I hand
it to him
and he takes it and he looks at it and
he looks at me and he says
he says is this a joke and I said no why
he said because I wrote this
is my poem
so I had had uh his poem in my wallet
for however many years I think it was
um five or six years
so as soon as he said that I think I
I think you know I think my mind
exploded and I think I you know I just
sort of melted
um
and so our connection was like
instantaneous and I and it felt
um
it felt magical it felt um like it was
meant to be
boom here was this guy he had written
this poem
and it had been in my wallet the whole
time
and so we um
I mean so we were like from that moment
on pretty much we were inseparable
um
and
I think I think it was after like two
weeks maybe two weeks so I mean like
seeing each other every day all day
we thought oh let's just move in with
each other
and so we did that
and then it was about
um
it was a few months later I think it was
exact I'll tell you because I know
exactly it was exactly four months to
the day after we met
um because we met on April
28th
of 2000 and 2009.
um
we decided that
we were going to get married
and at that time I believe there were
only two maybe three states in the
United States where you were a same-sex
couple could get married I think Hawaii
was one of them and
um uh possibly Vermont and Massachusetts
so we decided to go to Massachusetts
and get married in one of my favorite
places uh in the states which is uh
p-town Provincetown Massachusetts right
on Cape Cod
uh where there's a big thriving gay
community
so we actually uh drove because he's
from Chicago and so we drove across
country so we stopped in Chicago and so
I met all of his friends and I met all
of his family and then we stayed there
for about a week and then we drove from
Chicago to to New York where he met all
of my New York friends and my family in
New York and then we drove from New York
to Massachusetts where we got married on
the beach
in Provincetown very early in the
morning on
August 28th
2009.
um
and then we got in the car and we drove
back across the country back to the
United States and started our lives
together our life together as a married
couple
uh and everything everything was going
great and he was
um
38
I think he just turned 38 and I was a
few years older than him I think I was
42 maybe 45 I can't remember exactly
um
and I was at work one day
it was a Monday
I don't remember the exact date but I
could figure it out
um I was at work and he called me
and said that uh he had been home that
day and he was a uh I'll tell you that
he was a he was a chef
um and so he loves of course he was a
chef he loved to cook uh and I'm Italian
from the Bronx so I love to eat uh and
that was a big that was a big part of
our lives like and I was a lot heavier
because every day like I would wake up
and there would be a gigantic breakfast
and he was Puerto Rican and so at night
there would always be like a big uh
pernil which is uh like uh pork Pig
um we were constantly eating and he was
uh and he was uh he was very healthy he
went to the gym every day uh he was
really built like he was muscular he had
this fantastic body he was gorgeous
uh but he called me up I was at work he
called me up on this Monday morning and
he said that he had fainted and he
didn't he didn't feel well at all
um
and he was HIV positive but he was also
um uh undetectable so
there uh they did you know we weren't we
weren't concerned about that at all but
he said he fainted and he felt really
bad when he got back up he called me and
he said that he didn't feel feel well at
all he wasn't sure what was going on so
I suggested that he go to the
emergency room
which he did and I got out of work and I
I met him
at the hospital at Cedars here in Los
Angeles
um and like immediately when I got there
the and told them who I was looking for
I got to hit he was he had been admitted
into the ICU
which was very strange I thought and but
as soon as I got there the doctors
grabbed me and said
um that he was doing really bad
that he um he had an extremely low
number of platelets he was anemic
um
and that he had uh that he had cancer
that he had he had Non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma
and it had spread throughout his body
and it was like it was a it was stage
four
um and and he had no indication that
anything was wrong the entire time he he
again he felt great he looked great he
was muscular he went to the gym he had
energy he he ate I mean he had an
appetite like the whole thing so it was
um like it was it was really shocking
um
and so we didn't
we we had no idea what to do we didn't
know what to do but he was in the ICU
and they started giving him transfusions
I think over the time that he was in the
hospital they gave him something like 21
transfusions
or which is which is a crazy number
um but none of it was working his body
was not uh taking taking it at all it
was just like his his I guess his
platelet numbers
stayed that stayed the same like very
very low
and I think it was
so this was a Monday when he went into
the hospital I think Wednesday I was I
mean I was there in the hospital with
him every day all day of course
um
and then it was Wednesday I believe
where he he was just really really weak
and I was sitting there and I was
holding his hand and we were talking
and he said
um sorry
he said I don't want to die
because I just found you
and then he closed his eyes
and he went into a coma
so that was on Wednesday he was in a
coma for Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday
uh and then on Sunday
December 28th oh it was Christmas of
course and so of course we had decorated
our house it was our first Christmas
together and in fact
um because he was in the ICU uh he
couldn't really have visitors and also
they wouldn't even allow me to bring
Christmas gifts I had of course a whole
bunch of gifts that I was going to give
him for Christmas they would not allow
me to bring the gifts into the uh ICU
but we kept and we talked about this too
and he said don't worry it'll be fine
you know whenever we'll just have
Christmas as soon as I get back home
um
on Sunday December 28th
um he was in a coma and the cardiologist
came to me and and he's and he said that
um he said that he was that Antonio was
going to go into cardiac arrest
that he had maybe 15 minutes left
and he sat down he sat me down and he
explained to me what was about to happen
Antonio would go into cardiac arrest and
what they would have to do in order to
try to save him was they would have to
um
cut open his chest they would have to
break his ribs
move his ribs out of the way and work on
his heart like like with their with his
act the cardio cardiologist with his
actual hands like try to work on it uh
but he said like looking at
um
looking at it he said I can tell you
right now it's not it's not going to
work
you know we'll probably work on him for
about 45 minutes uh but it's I'm telling
you it's not going to work there's no
way that
we're going to to be able to save him
what do you want to do
what do I want to do I don't know I
don't know and I so I thought about it I
guess for a second although I was
completely in shock and
um and I said well
if it's not going to work and
why put him through all of that
let's just stop
um and by the way
um the reason why they were asking me
what I wanted to do was because I had a
marriage certificate which is why it's
so important I had a legal document
saying that I was his partner that I was
his husband
um
otherwise they would not have let me
into the ICU
just by the way
uh so I said okay I guess we should stop
so as soon as I said that literally they
were like okay let's go and so a room
full of like doctors and nurses
ran out of the room and they took all of
the um
took everything with them they took the
monitors they they unhooked things they
gone the only thing that was left was a
ventilator because he had been on a
ventilator
um because his uh his organs had started
shutting down his his liver
shut down and his kidneys were about to
shut down they were talking about at one
point during that day putting him on
dialysis
and all this stuff
but at any rate as soon as I said okay
let's stop they were gone
the only thing left was the ventilator
so he was breathing
and
I didn't know what to do and there was
this very kind nurse
who saw that I was just like
just like stunned and didn't know what
to do and she said talk to him
she said because somewhere somewhere in
there he can hear you okay
so I got into bed I crawled into bed
with him and I held him
and I started talking to him and I told
him how much I loved him
and I told him that I said don't worry
about me
because I'll be okay
and I said and I said don't be afraid
because whatever is going to happen to
you now is going to be
great and fascinating and
probably wonderful and
and I held I just held him
um
and he was on the ventilator like I said
so he kept breathing
but even though he was breathing
there was a very clear moment
where I knew that he was gone
that he had died
I could feel it
it became very clear to me in an instant
that he was gone
that the
person I knew that Antonio was gone and
that what was here with me at that
moment
was just his body
it was just very clear to me
even though he was still breathing
and
so I stayed there for a long time
nobody came nobody bothered me they just
let me stay there as long as I wanted
until I finally
I don't know how long I was there uh but
then I finally thought okay
it's time for me to go
so I left
um
and then I went home
and
um this might possibly have been the
worst part of it in fact I went home and
of course there was a Christmas tree
with all of our Christmas gifts
so it took me many years in fact after
that for me to be able to enjoy
Christmas again because that you know
um
and I remember I sat in my apartment for
probably
two weeks
and I don't remember eating
I know I lost a lot of weight
um I I think I was
I must have been in shock I was just I
was just completely stunned
um
I remember it must maybe two or three
weeks later
I I remember this very distinctly
sort of getting up
it was very hard to sleep I maybe slept
two maybe three hours a day
mostly I just sat and just kind of like
it was in my head
I remember there was there was this one
day where I I stood up and I looked out
the window of our apartment and I saw
there were people outside they were they
were human beings like walking around
and and there were cars driving by
and
I remember very distinctly thinking
like something something is wrong
something is really wrong people don't
you understand like what are you doing
the world has ended
how are you outside like how are you
walking how like how are you having
lives how are you talking to each other
I didn't understand because
in my mind the world had ended
um
so I did that for a long time
um
and then finally of course
um I realized at one point maybe a
couple of months later I realized that I
really needed help
um so somehow I found a a a grief
Therapy Group I found a group of people
there were eight of us in this group
um who all had lost spouses around the
same time so they put this this place
they put this uh group together
the place is called our house here in
Los Angeles and they put this group
together of eight people and we
committed to a year and a half of grief
therapy so we went through this whole
grief
process for a year and a half together
which was tremendous
tremendously helpful
um
and
I told them the story of course
and
of course they all wanted to hear the
poem
which I still have
in my wallet
a little piece of paper
the poem is called wait for him
wait for the guy who calls you beautiful
instead of hot
who calls you back when you hang up on
him who stays awake just to watch you
sleep
who worries and takes care of you when
you are ill
wait for the guy who kisses your
forehead
who wants to show you off to the world
when you're wearing sweats
who holds your hand in front of his
friends
wait for the guy who is constantly
reminding you of how much he cares about
you and how lucky he is to have you
wait for the guy who turns to his
friends and says
that's him
wait for the guy who only wants you
and his name was uh Antonio Mojica and
when we got married he took my name so
his name was Antonio Mojica Vaccaro
and
it took me a long time
I think to be able to
live in the world again like a normal
human being
um
I remember this very distinctly it was
about two years later
two years two full years
when I laughed for the very first time
that I could remember since his death
I laughed I laughed out loud at
something I don't remember what I
laughed at but I laughed out loud and it
was this laugh that
you know that had been waiting two years
to come out of me
and I was so filled with joy at the idea
that I laughed but that only lasted a
second
um
because then I felt horrible for
laughing I thought
I can't possibly laugh I can't possibly
enjoy life ever again because then that
would be a betrayal if I wasn't
miserable for the rest of my life that
would be a betrayal to him
um but it took me a while to realize
that that of course was
insane
um
and that I had to figure out a way to
be a happy person to be a happy normal
person
and so that it's been quite a few years
now
um of course I still think about him
every single day
I still
um miss him
I went through a very long period of
time when I was where I would be home
for instance and I would I lived in an
apartment building I would be home and I
would hear somebody some keys jangling
out the hallway
and I would immediately I would think
oh
Antonio's home
or there would be times where something
something really wonderful would happen
in my life I'd get some great job or
something or something really fun
happened and my first thought was to
pick up my phone and call Antonio was
like
oh I can't right still happens to me all
these years later
uh but I have figured out how to
um get maneuver through life and be a
happy person and I realized that this
grief
will always be a part of me we'll always
be a part of who I am always and and
that's really fine
I'm really okay with that
so I met Antonio on
April 28th
2009 and he died exactly we got married
exactly four months later
August 28th and he died on December 28th
we had exactly eight months together
uh but it was it was eight months of
living with a rock star
and it will always be a part of me
that's my story
beautiful